there's an irony in trying to get people
to do their best work but particularly
to try new things and to innovate in
that very often the kind of
characteristics that are common to
someone who will have a good new idea
have no overlap with the characteristics
that are common to someone who's really
good at presenting in meetings so it's
kind of like the difference between like
sales and R&D right so the people that
are in your sales or marketing division
in a company are very different kind of
person the people you have in R&D or
something else like that
the problem is if you do the traditional
route of trying to encourage innovation
by having meetings and let's say let's
brainstorm and talk about what you think
a good idea might be the problem is that
the people who might be very best at
innovating are often the people who are
very worse at presenting in a meeting
like that or selling their ideas one
piece of evidence in that argument is
the fact that so many true innovators
don't work in groups you have to fail a
lot when you innovate and failure in a
public setting can really hurt your
self-esteem and your self-confidence so
you need to create an environment where
people really can be empowered to fail
you